barely two weeks since her daughter was
fatally shot Olivia Pratt corbell's
mother Cheryl remembers her adored
little girl
everyone that she met they all fell in
love with her
she left her more on everyone that she
met
and she may well have only been nine
but she packed a lot in them nine years
her bandaged wrist is a reminder of the
bullet that both injured her and took
her daughter's life speaking to
merseyside police her memories of Olivia
read like the happiest of childhoods she
was amazing
she loved life
she was me a little Shadow she went
everywhere with me here it is because
she never never stopped talking
and that's what I miss the most
because I couldn't talk
it was late evening on the 22nd of
August when a masked gunman forced his
way into her home and there was gunfire
yeah
[Music]
Olivia here with her father to Christmas
Market in Liverpool was an innocent
victim he too paid tribute to his
nine-year-old girl
Olivia's future has been cruelly
snatched away from her and we have been
deprived of a real light in our lives
Olivia's death cannot be in vain and we
want people to feel safe and be safe and
that could only happen if we all come
together and make sure there is no place
for guns or those who use guns on our
streets or in our communities
a plea echoed by Olivia's mother the
weapons used that night are yet to be
found
if anyone is hiding these guns
they need to speak up
because they need to be off these
streets
no one no one at all should have to go
through this
closest to her pleading for justice for
a life cut crawly short
Sky News in Liverpool